so on that topic let me ask
uh again there's a million technical
things
uh we could talk about but let me ask
the absurd
the old philosophical question about
life
what do you hope when you look back at
your life
and people talk about you right about
you
500 years from now what do you hope your
legacy is
people not being afraid to take a leap
of faith
um i mean i you know i've got this
this kind of weird history of doing
weird stuff and
um it worked out pretty damn well it
worked out
right and i think some of the weirder
stuff that i've done
um has been the coolest and some of it
some of it crashed and burned and
um yeah you know i think well over half
of the stuff that i've done has crashed
and burned
um which has occasionally been really
annoying
but still you kept doing it but yeah
yeah yeah and you know there you know
you even when things crash and burn you
you at least learn something from it by
way of advice
you know people developers engineers
scientists or just people who are young
uh to look up to you what advice would
you give them
how to uh how to approach their life
don't be afraid of risk it's okay to do
stupid things once
[Laughter]
maybe even a couple times you know you
you know you get
you get a pass on the the first time or
two that you do something stupid
you know the third or fourth time yeah
not so much
but also you know
i don't know why but really early on
i started to think about um
ethical choices in my life um
and because i a big science fiction fan
um i i i got to thinking about
like just about every technical decision
i make
in terms of how do you want you know are
you building blade runner or star trek
which one's better which which future
would you rather live in
you know so what's what's the answer to
that well i would just
i would sure rather live in the universe
of star trek soundtrack
yeah that opens up a whole topic about
ai but that's a really interesting
yeah yeah yeah that's a it's a really
interesting idea so your favorite ai
system would be data
uh from uh from star trek my least
favorite would
easily be skynet yeah beautifully put i
don't think there's a better way to end
it james
i can't say enough how much of an honor
it is to meet you to talk to you thanks
so much
for wasting your time with me today not
a waste at all
thanks james all right thanks
you